بنزيما يواصل اثاره الجدل تعويض لارمله
بتسعه وعشرين مليون دولار فرنسا تودع
الاسطوره هذه الاخبار وغيرها تتابعون على
العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
كريم بنزيما الفائز بالكره الذهبيه يبدو
انه لم يتقبل الى الان بجائزه الافضل فاد
ريال مدريد عاد لاثاره الجدل على السوشيال
ميديا بعد نشره الاحصائيات في السنه
الماضيه عبر السوري على انستجرام كما نشر
صوره له مع زميله فينيسيوس جونيور في
اشاره لاستبعاد البرازيليه من الفريق
المثالي للعام الحالي وحل بنزيما ثالثا في
تصويت فيفا خلف مبابي الذي بقي هادئا على
السوشيال ميديا
بعد عده سنوات من الغائه اعاده ادارته
بايرن ميونخ لائحه عقوبات على اللاعبين في
حل ارتكابهم باي مخالفه داخل منشات النادي
كالوصول المتاخر للتدريبات او مخالفه
لوائح الانضباط وتتراوح الغرامات بين الف
يورو و 3000 يورو هذه اللائحه علقت في غرف
في ملابس اللاعبين ولادت منها هو اطفاء
روح التعاون والاحترام بين اللاعبين وليس
جمع الاموال وهذا بحسب مدير النادي
في خبرنا الاخير توفي الاسطوره الفرنسيه
عن عمر النهز 89 وكان المولود في المغرب
قد بدا مسيره الكرويه مع نادي الاتحاد
المغربي قبل ان يرحل الى فرنسا كما شارك
في كاس العالم عام 58 وحقق وقتها رقما
قياسيا بتسجيليه 13 هدفا في نسخه واحده من
المونديال وهو رقم لا يزال صامدا حتى الان